what makes a skin
good it's gonna look good obviously
you've got to
really want to use it and for many
people the rarer the skin is
the better but sometimes though being
rare just
isn't enough which is why in today's
video we're going to be focusing on the
skins that also have
incredible stories behind them these are
the top 10
rarest skins in esports
coming in at number 10 are the dream
hack winter 2013
cs go major souvenir drops now a number
of these
are apparently so rare they're one of a
kind
but the one we want to talk about
specifically is the granite
marble eye souvenir p2000
factory new a one-of-a-kind skin
that has gone missing according to
youtuber
tdm jesus now this granite marbleized is
actually fairly interesting because
no one actually knows where it is the
last guy to have this skit was a guy
called
mac from sweden in his steam profile
comments
you can see well-known skin collector
frank furda inquiring about the skin
back in 2018 but there's no reply
since then it's disappeared from mac's
inventory and seems to have vanished off
the face of the earth
no one really knows where it's ended up
although judging by the look of mac or
my guess would be at the bottom of the
river with 500 kilograms of submit on
its feet
that's right this is a scheme so rare
that we have
no idea who owns it if you're out there
and you happen to have this skin
maybe let us know we'll definitely take
it off your hands
slipping into number nine on our list
are the black eye skins
the operation black ice expansion for
rainbow six siege brought the black ice
weapon skins
now they had less than a two percent
drop rate when opening an alpha pack
which explains why people went a little
bit nuts for them
oh epic black guys oh
[ __ ] let's go unlike many of the skins
on this list
you cannot buy black ice you have to
roll the dice on alpha packs
get an epic and then pray that epic is a
black eye skin
then hope you got black ice for a gun
that you
actually use that kind of rarity goes a
long way to explaining
these kinds of reactions oh oh purple
purple purple
oh i got black guys for buck sea eight
next up at number eight we have the
peabody skin
i'm gonna have a target on my back the
whole time every ever dude
the entire day okay so before you say
anything i know you can go out right now
and get this one but there's a pretty
crazy
story behind this fall guy's skin in
august 2020 the four guys account
tweeted out that they given a new
costume early to
quote the player who is statistically
the best
the community wondered who the hell that
was they were only referred to in the
tweet as
the fallen one for two days nobody knew
and then dr lupo took a closer look at
his account
no way no way
ah man oh look at me at the front
little robot let's go the skin was
eventually made available to everyone
but for those
two days dr lupo was the only one in the
world who had it
tim the tatman thought he deserved it
but lupo used the opportunity to put him
back in his place
replied to the tweet and said yes and
give it to me i said might be
appropriate you're a bot at this game
next up at number seven we have the
galaxy skin now to understand
just how rare this fortnite skin is you
only have to hear people's reaction to
seeing it in game
oh my god no way you don't even see the
galaxy skin that's going to come
it is thousand dollars they're freaking
out
the skin was available for a limited
time to those who logged into their
account
through their pre-ordered samsung galaxy
s9 phone
or a samsung galaxy note 9 each one
costing over a
thousand dollars lots of people told me
that once you get the
the tab s4 like any i think the phone
all you guys have to do is sign into
your account and play through
three full games and you guys should get
the galaxy skin so
the deal has been over for quite some
time now which means this skin
will only continue to amaze players that
run into it
you are so beautiful man i love you
thank you my friend wow
at number six we have the steam golem
who's been left out in the rain
rusty blitzcrank this blitzcrank skin
entered the league of legends store in
november 2009
that's less than a month after the
league was released as its name suggests
it's a re-imagination of normal
blitzcrank
except now he's rusty perhaps not the
biggest re-imagination then
as bizzleberry points out first time
using the skin
it looks like normal blitzcrank but
rusty i guess
hence the name it wasn't the wildest
skin
and blitz players felt a little hard
done by the skin was pulled from the
store after just
three months and thrown in the legacy
vault and hosie games says he knows
exactly why riot did this
this skin looked too much like the base
skin the yellow base skin
and it was just discontinued for that
reason they're like it looks too
similar to the base skin whoever's
bought it already you guys can keep it
but we're gonna just pull the skin
that's what happened it has never been
available for purchase
since and there's only one way to get it
now
you have to own every other skin
in the game some people who do that have
said that they then
message riot and we're given a list of
legacy skins to choose from
with rusty blitzcrank on that list so
that means if you ever do see a rusty
blitzcrank in-game
they've either been playing since the
very beginning or
they dropped about five thousand dollars
to buy all the other skins first
whatever it takes i guess
at the number five spot now we have king
ramos
this one is simple it is the
rarest skin in league of legends this is
arguably the rarest skin in league if
you're not counting north america and
brazil
um because this skin has only been
obtainable
into those two servers this skin only
belongs to players who were invited into
the league of legends
closed beta back in 2009 which
only took place in north america and
brazil although it might look a little
bit plain by today's standards the skin
is actually inspired by
bowser from super mario wait
wait wait wait wait a minute there's
been a bit of a mix-up
you're not the right bowser only about
250 000
players signed up to the beta which
means at most there are only a quarter
of a million people
rolling around in their skin and
probably a whole lot less than that
so this possibly if you actually took on
how many people
in current day league of legends has use
of this account of this skin
this might be the lowest
coming in at number four are the
champions choice costumes from street
fighter 5
winners of the capcom cup street
fighters world championship
get to design their own skin that gets
put into the game
so far we've had costumes from the likes
of kazunoko
knuckle do gachikun and idont
god i don't believe it and for the first
time this weekend
idom actually reacts and look how much
it means to him
now anyone can buy these skins but the
world champions get something
truly rare each capcom cup champion gets
a unique version of their skin
put on their street fighter 5 account
these skins are usually
very similar but have one small key
difference
for example mena rd's personal
one-of-a-kind birdie skin
has his hair cut and gachikoon's unique
rasheed skin
features the players earrings and a
wedding ring so the good news is that
these skins
are obtainable you just kind of have to
be the best player in the world to get
them though
no big deal from the dominican republic
he is your team come 2017 champion
at number three we have the party hat
now if you've
ever touched runescape the party hat
will strike a chord with you
they are the most valuable items in
runescape 3.
for the white party hat dream
oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god
they were first available from opening a
christmas cracker
during the 2001 christmas event and are
purely cosmetic
in nature they don't offer any stats at
all
they just come in pretty colors soon
after their release though they were
discontinued which caused their value to
rise to
insane levels it was actually around 1.2
billion for
40 years or so up to this point and then
it just started going up
since january 2015 and never stopped
up up to the max cash stack and up to
3.4 billion
crazy officially a party hat is worth
over
2.1 billion gold in runescape 3
according to runescape wiki
that's just the maximum amount of gold
that can be stacked in one go though
and some estimates put some of their
worth such as the blue party hat
at 13 billion gold or more it's been
almost two decades since their release
now
and it's thought there are just a few
hundred party hats left in existence
next up at the number two spot we have
golden bzz
pugner
now the real name for dota's gold and
bzz pugna skin
is the golden nether lords regalia set
but it's named after the russian pro
player bzz or
633 it's confusing i know but what's
important
is that there are just 25 copies of this
skin
in dota 2. golden bzz pugna was only
available as a
random drop from the trust of the
benefactor 2016
treasure and there are only 25 copies in
existence
so you'd be seriously lucky to see one
of these in-game
it is indescribably rare just
two years ago a person who had this skin
in their account
was offered 18 000
for it f's in the chat then for another
guy who sold his bzz pugner set
early on for 3.50
ouch and finally
number one we have the m4a4 how
this story is pretty much so buckle up
back in 2013
valve encouraged artists in the cs go
community to design
and upload skins to the steam workshop
if their designs received enough upvotes
the skin would be implemented into the
game
that's exactly what happened the
following year when a skin called
howling dawn was uploaded by steam users
aussie and sick
now ozzy said the image was inspired by
a picture of his
dog alex jaygay explained just how the
skin
took off from there since the artwork
provided by
sick and aussie got so much positive
feedback not only did it make it onto cs
go but also into the huntsman collection
the skin was added to the game and soon
people were clamoring to get themselves
the new
m4a4 howl
oh my god
what the f that's factory dude dude it
seemed like a great success story
until in june 2014 a deviantart user
called
canis albus came forward to say that
wait for it
the dog design was actually theirs
after a dmca notice valve redesigned the
skin for any
new buyers but the old ones were left as
they
are tdm jesus explained what happened
next the import a4 how was given a new
coat of paint
and it was made contraband and the same
would happen for the howling dawn
sticker
this limited edition contraband became a
collector's item almost overnight
to give you guys an idea of just how
rare this piece of csgo history is
an original m4a4 howl was sold earlier
this year
for 100 000
it's crazy to think just how valuable
this skin has become
just because some shitty person ripped
off an artist
all right folks we've reached the end of
the video i hope you enjoyed that and
now
i'm gonna ask if you can please
subscribe if you haven't done so already
we are on our way to two million subs
it's a very big number we're very
excited so please help us get there if
you haven't subscribed already
thanks for watching and i'll see you all
in the next one
yeah so i was thinking about the fact
that um if you win
worlds my thing is like do you pick one
that's cool
or do you pick one that you know will
sell a lot because you get a cut of the
money
right you might like hate ezreal you
know you might hate ezreal
and looks but like they're gonna sell a
hell of a lot more than yorick skins i'm
just saying
i think there's too much planning going
on for someone who's definitely not
going to win worlds ever i think i'm
i probably need to give up this dream
but yeah just a thought